hi guys welcome to the just pearly songs
youtube channel and today i'm going to
be reacting to
n l e choppa shot up flow
i've never heard of it before but you're
gonna see me blindly react
before i start the video do not forget
subscribe subscribe subscribe as you
guys know
trying to move out of my parents house
do not forget to subscribe and comment
what video should i do next
and tell me did i get the analysis right
did i get it wrong
i don't know let me know
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
okay so i'm starting the video and i
so i've been learning from the last
video it looks like he's in some sort of
gang
because he is with a lot of his friends
with a lot of guns in a house that's not
very nice i learned that this might be a
trap house
i don't really know what goes on in the
trap house but this is what i'm learning
so what he
is saying is that he started some stuff
and
he is going to finish so when you
start something you can't just let it
like you know like i say walk away
why would you keep you know like
engaging in
conversation that's not helpful to you
but he's saying he
started this stuff he is going to finish
[Music]
with the gang you know we buying it what
is your [ __ ] what is you claiming i am
obese
you
okay so he's saying that he is a beast
so aka he is very cool cooler than
everyone else clearly and
he's also harder than everyone else
because
if someone points a finger at him they
might some stuff might go down
it's a threat i'm not gonna lie hey
[ __ ] plotting oh we got money i'm
running this wallet you say you a killer
little [ __ ] stop it in the shoot out yo
okay so he's saying that in a shootout
the other person's gun
is dropping so what he's saying is that
he
is braver than the other guy like
he's not afraid of anything
what's going on here you cannot stop on
his jaw
so he made some innuendos like it
sounded like
he he named some guy let me listen to
that again hold on
[ __ ] don't sweat me chopper got a kid
called that [ __ ] jelly
said tapa got a kid call that [ __ ]
jet li i i don't know what that means
but i think it was clever
like i think if i knew what that meant
it would be clever
so he asked what is your recipe now
i have a lot of recipes so i'd like to
know like do you want a casserole
recipe do you want like you know
um i make some good french toast like i
got a lot of recipes i could share so
my question would be like what kind of
recipe
are you looking for but i don't think
that's a bad lyric to have in the song
you know
whole lot of dwelling hit the party 50
these known by my shadows
nick turned me so you know i had to pop
them so many bullets that confused the
doctor
whole lot of wrecks whole lot of stakes
[ __ ] a head shot imma shoot him in the
back
3.5 rolled up in the cat will
okay so he's talking about he is above a
certain type of weed
i don't know what kind of weed he's
saying that he's like above
but he only smokes a certain type of
weed
[Music]
so he said your [ __ ] is sucking
dick like a kool-aid pistol i think so
that doesn't make sense to me because
one why is his like this other girl that
has like is clearly like taken
suck in his dick like she shouldn't do
that and second up
like a kool-aid pistol that just pistol
that just doesn't make sense
so i don't know what that means
so he's saying that he's gonna get rich
or die
trying look i think that's admirable
i think it's good to have goals and to
chase after those goals
[Music]
so he's saying that he feels like he's
kobe you know kobe is a cool guy
uh rest in peace but cool guy um and he
made a lot of shots so i think this
guy's saying like
he is okay with risk and taking a lot of
shots and he makes them
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
so he says something about he's with
this [ __ ] little homie like i'm toby
who is toby because when i think of toby
i think of the hr
guy from the office who's always writing
people up
for hr stuff and you don't want to be
like that toby so
i'm thinking there's a different toby
out there that's all so
cool who i don't know i don't know
[Music]
okay so it looks like they're doing this
thing where all their friends
make a circle right and in the middle of
the circle people
are dancing now this is interesting um
like they're just outside a house with a
bunch of friends
the gang i'm assuming and dancing and
like honestly
from what i understood i thought gangs
were doing some bad stuff
and this is looking like he's they're
just like dancing having some wholesome
fun and i think that's great like if you
want to improve your dance moves
go for it i think that's great
oh that's it that's the end of the song
but i think it was a good song
like out of 10 i'd maybe give it like
a seven there wasn't like the themes
were very simple like i am cool
i won't back down if i'm in a fight and
you know he's like cool like
kobe so that's fine messaging
you know like if you don't want to back
down in a fight like that's fine
um yeah seven out of ten i thought the
beat was fun
i liked that there was some wholesome
dancing they waved around the guns but
didn't shoot so that's great
yes 7 out of 10 i'd recommend if you
enjoyed this analysis
do not forget to subscribe to my channel
trying to move out of my parents house
every subscriber helps i swear
it helps second thing don't forget to
comment
comment what video should i do next and
comment did i get it right
did i get it wrong anyways i'm having a
lot of fun
i'ma talk to you guys later